you
you didn't get beat up by nina you got
beat up by an asian lady who wouldn't
stop saying the n word whoa you were
there and you didn't jump in and help
bro that part whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
again asian people are saying the n-word
now oh we got to remaster all the rush
hours jacket gun can't you see him
hanging off a chandelier doing comfort i
can't believe you didn't help me you
watched her pour a mango margarita on my
head no
i left before that
it just didn't seem right to get
involved in a domestic violence
situation it wasn't a domestic violence
situation bro we don't even live
together it was just regular violence
you dumbass that doesn't seem right but
bro i'm not just some random [ __ ] you
know me
i taught you how to put dryer sheets on
the ac so that smell would go away
that's the homie it feels me
i gotta [ __ ] the [ __ ] up well you're
not allowed to [ __ ] [ __ ] up even in
honor of other [ __ ] mm-hmm wow we
have strayed so far from god's light but
she's the homie i would want to jump in
too but i'd be afraid to break out into
a threesome you know threesomes turning
into or just real quick bodies
everywhere everybody all the naked and
all that more importantly why were you
in that mean asian lady fighting in the
first place i mean
her name's tiki and she's my savage
oh my god are you you're cheating on me
why are you whispering she's not here
because i'm devastated she makes you
pasta anyway in a series of unfortunate
events
tiki ended up pregnant and now she's
trying to say it's my baby yo that [ __ ]
is confusing my brain is so hard bruh
like i don't know man it kind of all
just happened you know
we met at this furniture store
you know what i mean
we're both looking at the same circle
bed with the little rhinestones in the
headboard you know some [ __ ] nina
would've never let me buy for her i'll
let you buy that [ __ ] you're broke chris
yes that's true
but me and tiki like hit it off
she's just so like wow man and free
and she paints little minions on her
fingernails
sexy that's nice but but why cheat right
were you were you unhappy
was nina making you lift stuff it's not
even about nina i'm a [ __ ] cafeteria
lady every day starts with scrambled
eggs and ends with watching four
weddings but when i'm with tiki and
she'd be arguing with bank tellers over
overdrive fees i feel like future hey we
all deserve to eat [ __ ] with sunglasses
on sometimes exactly
so when she said she wanted a baby i
threw the bread for some in vitro okay
wait so you just paid for the baby
mm-hmm everybody knows the rules if it's
not your load nothing is old
respectfully i disagree if it's not your
splatter it doesn't matter if it's not
your gravy see you later later if it's
not your juice you ain't got to read
mother goose chris
we got it all right yeah
look although you didn't traditionally
nut in tiki you did however financially
nut in tiki and that makes what grew
from that nut your responsibility well i
used nida's credit card to pay for it so
according to your logic it's nina's baby
[ __ ]
even future wouldn't do that i mean it
wasn't supposed to be all this tiki was
just supposed to be a messy getaway
that's what side pieces are for yeah but
did you ever do non-side-piece things
with her like rub her back or listen to
her dreams of course i did that's how
you get [ __ ] but that doesn't mean i'm
trying to be with her forever i gave the
[ __ ] a baby i wasn't trying to have a
baby with a [ __ ] right like if i buy a
girl a turtle i don't have to keep
sending them lettuce or calling it on
his birthday yeah
and i met up with her last night to cool
things off but then tiki got all wild on
samari [ __ ] and now i think she's gonna
blow my whole life up i could feel her
walls closing in on me and now no of
course not her [ __ ] walks what a shame
call to action the real culprit here is
the man who's nut made that baby in the
first place i think she got it from like
a sperm bank or something exactly
downloading downloading if he would have
never nutted in that cup then tiki would
have never had that baby if tikki never
had that baby then sam never would have
got her ass beat and banned for one of
america's premier homecoming restaurants
if so fact though that means that that
man is a deadbeat a woman beater and is
still allowed to go to the fondue
factory when our friend is not [ __ ]
right yes
i'm going down to that sperm bank and
i'm gonna go find whose nut it is and
i'm going to to talk to somebody because
i'm a customer there and i need to
figure out how to check my account
balance online
no oh sorry sorry to hold you up i know
you got a lot going on but chris
do you think that the sperm bank works
like a regular bank i'm sorry one second
man i gotta open this garage on this
no
i can't watch the point i like to watch
at a regular bank you haven't seen like
three [ __ ] on our giraffes just
[ __ ] the giraffe's happy but he wet
you don't know [ __ ] about sex
if you [ __ ] on a giraffe it's still
bestiality
[Music]
you